welcome to corridor crew today you're
going to learn learn how to fall
hey everybody we are joined today by the
lovely and talented guitar
he is a professional stunt man and he's
going to teach us and you
how to do actual stunt falls basically
all those movies where you see the guys
just taking the mega hits well there's a
technique to it so that you don't hurt
yourself
gee is the magician he's going to reveal
his secrets for us
if you're trying to get in the stunts
watch this video and then
go practice these techniques over and
over and over again because
it's always good to refresh it anyway
even if you know what you're doing to an
extent because
your body still has to remember it be
mindful stretch
warm up warm up after two good cool down
okay now i've i've watched a couple of
videos
you know i think i figured it out so
like if you take a big hit it's all
about like
straight knees and it looks like this
you just want oh if you land like that
you're like a cat
easily nothing breaks don't do that
there are three falls that you should
definitely know how to do that stem
and branch out to all the other falls
that you'll do in the future front we
need to learn how to fall forward
without smashing our face into the
concrete
side we have to learn how to hit on our
sides without
breaking a tailbone and back we have to
learn how to fall on our backs properly
without hurting ourselves
and these three falls literally you're
gonna do with every job i've done these
falls
over and over and over again because i
trained it so much i'm able to do these
falls on the day when they need me to at
the last second
and i can bust it out and not get hurt
get back up and they can call me in for
the next day
if you're watching this video and you go
and try this stuff be safe you're gonna
try to find that line probably hurt
yourself it's not on us it's on you
work your way up because you know what
if you break your arm to make it harder
to keep doing things
with that arm in the future right ren
no how many bones have you broken at
least 13 but that's beside the point
um only for the age of 12.
literally falling down you're great for
this i would be lying if i said i was
not
concerned a little bit we're gonna break
it down bit by bit
build you guys up and then we'll start
getting more and more into the falls so
i'm gonna show you guys first
how to do it safe and i'm gonna show you
how to perform it
i'm going to start with backfall and i
want to start with getting you guys in
the right position first
this is where we want most of our
contact we don't want any contact here
we don't want any contact here we
definitely contact here
keep your chin tucked up but you don't
hit the back of your head hanging back
your head is not a good thing
really focus on keeping your chin to
your chest
that's very important okay you're gonna
lay down on this mat one at a time
your feet are gonna be flat on the floor
your palms are gonna be flat you're
gonna try to avoid your elbows from
smashing into the ground right you're
gonna
slap with your hands and i want you to
raise your hips up and i'm not putting
any weight on my heels
so i'm trying my best to keep everything
on the balls of my feet
and my tailbone off the ground this is
the position i want to see you guys in
cool so it's like nice one
two three why is he slapping the mat
so what it does is it disperses energy
so rather than staying just
in your shoulders you're letting that
energy go from your shoulders
into the ground we like to think of it
as i'm hitting the ground not getting
hit by it
take the fight to the ground so now that
we have
the basic position for when we do a back
fall that's the position we want to land
on right
we're going to start very slow and i
just want you guys to go from
here down
you look like spiderman there for a
moment is that why stunt guys when they
fall they go like oh
that's the way how they hide it so we're
just rolling get used to getting into
that position from another movement
oh oh my head yeah and that's where you
find
why you need to tuck your chin if your
neck is loose that thing going to swing
back
[Applause]
you're so pointy dude let's actually do
a fall we're gonna do
our first version of a backfall it's
gonna be very low
and it's very fast the idea is that
a rug has been swept from under your
feet so now your feet are gonna go
forward
you're going to get to your shoulders
you're going to keep your hips off the
ground and
we're going to perform at the same time
during your fighting stance the rugged
sweat
dude you did like a little kick it's to
help with the speed of me coming down
the faster i come down
the easier it is for me because if i
don't use my feet watch this
i'm more likely going to either catch my
foot
under me which is not good not a good
position to be in
so i'm kicking my feet out to give that
energy that i need to get to the higher
part of my shoulder
start with your knees bent you can be a
little bit closer to the ground it might
help you
give you a little spring
nice so now i want you to do it again
and i want you to hide the fact that you
have your hips up off the ground
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you did it looked like you hit your
head a little bit
oh nice performance dude all right that
was better
hell yeah i mean this is day one for us
right yeah yeah so this you guys are
doing great for day one
and nice
a little bit late so when i'm tucking my
chin am i like specifically trying to
press my chin against my sternum here or
i like to think i'm trying to keep it as
much foot as tight as i possibly can
i'm slapping and i'm trying to push as
hard as i can
into my chest because i know that the
moment i hit
then i can relax and go into my
performance
nice that's going to take some practice
it's just getting my
chin tucked because i focused on it and
i still once i hit i was like i don't
know if i did it well how's the back of
your head feel i hit it
but not hard not hard right nice
nice how's your neck feel my neck feels
better
actually that one felt good this is a
lot more challenging than it looks
like i'm actually surprised at how hard
this is there's a lot going on there's a
lot to think about and you're trying to
run through it all
and then like you'll do one of the
things but then you forgot about the
other three
all right so you have to do it so many
times that you do all these things
instinctually
so now we're going to do side floor and
to be surprised this position right here
as
seductive as it is is actually very
close to what it is that you want to be
when you do a side fall i have this hand
here to help with impact
i have this hand here with impact with
my shoulder being protecting my head
i am going to be pushing with my back
foot
up to keep space right here so when my
tailbone doesn't smash
into the ground so this foot is actually
also turned all your points are
protected i just want to see you guys
get in this position naturally once you
make impact there is going to be some
rotation to your back
or to your front
yeah nice good
watch that hand though you had it like
this palm down not up if you do this
more like you're gonna break your hand
or your wrist oh my god there's so many
different things to think about and they
all have to be done like that
[Laughter]
friend's dead everybody
now that we have the movement of it
right we're going to now go from a roll
to it so the idea is that somebody swept
your leg
you're right i'm good so this leg is
coming up
you're coming down bow first point of
contact with the mat
is going to be here my hands and back
wow nice
it's hard to get this toe down yeah it
is but as long as you're
thinking like hey i gotta get that over
to keep extra height off my hip
and my knee you're good to go you hit
that toe you got the toe
you got the toe i did i did
this i gotta do this
this is forever going to change the way
i go to bed
see you later sweet dreams nice
it's all like whiplash city i mean it's
not bad whiplash but it's definitely
like
my neck my neck you're gonna wake up
sore i promise you especially if this is
like your first time doing this
now we're gonna perform it somebody has
swept your leg
right my energy is kicking everything up
i'm slapping everything then my feet are
gonna come down
i'm gonna make sure my hip doesn't hit
and then i'm gonna perform more out of
it
good performance yeah how'd that feel a
little yeah i feel not bad but you feel
like a little bit a little bit a little
bit
what i'm teaching you doesn't take away
all of the pain
is acting acting you're doing a start on
set how do you know if somebody actually
hurts themselves they need to get in and
intervene and stop the shot
they never stopped the shot some guys
they never stop the shot for the sun
unless it's one of those like things i
was like oh god
however they'll wait for most parts
we'll do something we'll get thrown
through glass or we'll hit the ground
and then at the end of the take once
they say cut they'll be like is stunts
good
is everybody good and then you can
either go
or you go yeah i'm all right let's go
again
but you have to hold your tears yeah
pretty much or they just don't see it
because
you're not facing camera
you know i'm taking a break today to
tell you guys about our sponsor
bessie they make awesome shoes
they're comfortable stylish everyday
sneakers and
you know they look pretty sweet too
they're waterproof shoes you get water
all over these things
it's not even a problem all right
because water's gonna beat up fall off
they're super easy to clean you just
wash them with water
toss them in the washing machine done
this isn't your just generic everyday
shoe cloth
this is made from dymatex keeps you warm
in the winter
and cool in the summertime they're
sustainably made they're basically vegan
shoes
less material less waste no animal
products the shoes are basically vegan
so you don't have to feel guilty
because i know i don't i love doing
backlash and i love doing
freak flips with these shoes
it feels great click the link in the
description and use the code corridor
crew to get 25 bucks off for vessy's
holiday sale now it's the perfect time
to do so
it's the rainy season get it for your
friends get it for your family corridor
crew use the code 25 bucks off
let's get back to some more stunts with
clean we did our back fall we did our
side fall the third fall
front fall position that we're going to
be in the shakiest position ever
plank position i am not smashing my
elbows
into the ground not doing that i'm not
letting my face
hit the ground without my arms being in
the way first
we're using this surface of our body
here i'm keeping my groin off the ground
for you guys out there
you'll thank me i promise here bow and
then
you let it disperse can you how how high
of a fall will that save you
solid i saw it from like a split second
it's like one frame
you make the you make the frame and then
you go ah
i didn't realize you're actually going
to get some air off of that like you
went
up and horizontal with a little plank
nice now we're going to we're going to
work our way from just this is the
easiest place to do it from from our
knees
right we're going to drop we like to
make
kind of a triangle or diamond i feel
like this is the best structure
if anything goes wrong and i go down my
hands are there kind of to save my face
right so i'm like whoa ready
three two one
nice that was great that was really good
[Laughter]
i spent more take five dollars i buy
that two one
so now we're going to do it from
standing and what we're doing same
energy we're going to start low
and we're going to kick our legs back
this time so it goes three two
one
dude you literally dove into the mat
like we attack the ground when we do
stunts
nice whiplash from doing it that way
right
yeah now you actually have to put a
little more height
one go
for a second i saw you like kind of
rotate your arm in
i was like oh wait i landed here yes you
did if that was on concrete
you'd be very painful yes okay okay one
more time
oh that was pretty great that was
actually good no that was good
my nuts went just a little bit just a
little bit right
yeah you guys when you see me go it
looks like my feet are higher is because
i know that the moment i hit i can
probably engage my core and control
myself from smashing my nuts into the
ground
two one action that's great
so we've learned the three basic falls
we've added some performance to it
we're still a bunch of noobs but you
know what it's time for us to take
our tests see if we can step up from a
white belt to whatever the next level is
like a hand belt
we're going to do a live episode of
stuntmen react here where
we're going to react to corridor cruise
stunts this is going to be fun each one
is going to do
one of the falls wash paper scissors for
it one two
shoot all right
one oh yes so nico what are you what are
you gonna you know what i got the
biggest reaction with my front paw i'm
gonna stick with the front panel
now it's up for side and back i'm gonna
choose paper all right i'm two scissors
all right you have two points now
all right all right
oh man so what are you gonna do dude i'm
gonna get the the french painting
fall it's not good i was gonna choose
back anyway because i need to work on it
so y'all picture falls i'm right here at
the camera and i'm gonna be watching
every single frame and i'm gonna let you
guys know
where you got it right where you got it
wrong what you can improve
three two one
boom so there was no head reaction
nicely
you saved yourself that was good that
was good
yeah yeah okay cool not bad thanks you
just forgot the head reaction you gotta
remember that
there's not just the fall it's also the
impact of getting hit nico
gets a b perfect i give nico a b
so red got side fall right so ren you're
gonna get your legs swept
from under you sounds ready we're
rolling
and three two one
is red okay sounds good yeah i like
didn't do it at all i just
i just went down
late reaction good face
[Music]
didn't control his neck but he saved it
with his arm because he had good
placement where his arm was
way better to hit your arm than it is to
hit the concrete i would give that c
plus okay i was about to say i was like
that's not a b i almost froze
i was like huh how how do i do this
and that's why we practice non-stop
because even if your brain shuts off it
still knows
what it needs to do right i want that
stair fall
oh dude i'm blind goodness okay hold on
no
no okay no not really that's safe you're
gonna feel like you can do certain
things and you'll be like oh yeah yeah
yeah i got this
i'm gonna take it slow stunts ready
so exaggerated okay i want you to look
at this
preemptive thing you just did the like
yeah you're right you're wind up yeah we
should already be in a position where
we're already ready to go
you started in a position where you
weren't ready the guy you already
standing and then you had to get ready
and that took from your reaction and
then you fell right yeah that's my
secret
i'm always wound up
head reaction was too early and reaction
was against how the pan was working
so the pan would knock your head back
yeah which then would lead to your fall
got it so i'm gonna give you a beat
i'll take that you guys pass because
none of you guys got hurt
right which is very important i feel
great if ren feels great
we're good you didn't join the 14 bones
club
no 14th phone today stunt longevity
takes knowing the technique properly
and being able to perform while
remembering that technique and you guys
were able to perform and keep yourselves
able to get up and do it again
which is the most important thing about
stunts i've always had a tremendous
amount of respect for stunt performers
but actually
learning how to do this and all the
intricacies that i just never
comprehended before now like i have a
whole new level of respect for you guys
you guys did really good i just threw
three falls at you in the same day
and you each had to perform it and you
guys came out and you did your thing
and you all came with passing grades and
nobody broke anything yeah
does this mean i can finally be on
stuntman react
well that was fascinating it was really
cool to get that insight into the world
of stunts and falls and how to start
what goes into this profession because
it's such a mysterious and cool
profession
you guys should go check out gee's
instagram at gee ex to silva we'll have
a link in the description below check
out some of the cool stuff he's posted
and if you decide to start practicing
anything in this video
remember take it slow warm up stretch
out you have to treat it with a
professional mindset and a mature
mindset because you are going to be
taking your body
and starting to test the limits a little
bit don't hurt yourself